all right guys i just woke up a little
bit ago so that's why my voice is so
deep but um
the the newest trailer for eternals just
came out right the final trailer so
we're gonna fire this thing up we're
gonna react to it and uh i wonder if it
has anything new
i'm kind of excited to see what's in
this trailer hopefully it's better than
the first one because the first one
was cool but it wasn't all that great
okay ready
let's do this
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
the emergence is happening
how long do we have
seven days
[Music]
the calling of the planet
god i love the celestials
we're eternals
we came here 7000 years ago
[Music]
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history thank you kit
harrington
thank you we were instructed not to
interfere in any human conflicts unless
deviants are involved
by who
oh my god
oh my god
we need to find the others
oh
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
god i've loved these people since the
day we arrived
when you love something
[Applause]
you protect it why wasn't this the first
trailer wow
jesus
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Applause]
wow
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Laughter]
wow what a trailer okay
why was that not the first trailer right
why was that not the first trailer dude
the first trailer was just like eternals
exist
coming in november that was basically
the first trailer right and it's just
like okay i i love dude kid harrington
thank you
so much for asking that question in the
movie why haven't you guys done anything
okay there's some big differentiations
between like marvel comics and the
movies in terms of what they're doing
right the eternals having only been here
for seven thousand years uh and then
only really being here to protect
humanity from the deviants that's a big
change now it might be worthwhile for us
to do an origins and powers video on the
celestials and really even the eternals
here on on geek culture explain but to
give you guys a kind of quick and dirty
synopsis which might even be an even
more stripped down version than what
we'll do in the origins of powers videos
which are an even more stripped down
version what we do in comics explained
the important thing here is that the
eternals have been around for thousands
and thousands of thousands of years much
much longer than 7 000 years and and the
celestials basically showed up on earth
in the early days of mankind they had a
group called the wonderers which are
basically the missing link between
primate man and modern man and then
effectively they split them into three
groups right one group had their genes
modified to essentially become angelic
characters they were basically the
eternals the second group had their
genes destabilized to create unchecked
mutations those are the deviants the
third group had their genes modified so
that at some future point in time they
would get powers that's how you get
mutants in mobile comics but this is
cool man like this trailer is amazing
and the celestials look awesome oh my
god like the celestials look so
ridiculously good and i'm really hoping
that like they they are as imposing in
the movie as they are in the comics
because the celestials are colossal in
the comics god they're enormous now the
funny thing is they can do anything
right so they can change their size if
they want to they usually never do right
it's there's never really been an
instance where a celestial showed up on
earth and was like as tall as iron man
right like that's not very imposing at
all
but nonetheless the celestials are
fantastic i i love the idea of the
celestials and yeah we're going to do an
origins of powers and we're going to do
a really on the celestials anyway and
then we might do one on the eternals i
don't really know let me know in the
comments if you guys are interested in
that kind of stuff but this definitely
should have been the first trailer
something that i'm kind of astonished
about with regards to what they're doing
in the movie is they're largely keeping
the deviants under wraps and i know a
lot of people are speculating that this
is due to the fact that the deviants are
going to have a much bigger role and
possibly even allude to this idea that
the deviants are actually the ones that
have kind of been instigating war among
humanity for thousands of years but
nonetheless you know i'm i'm surprised
we're not really getting like full-on
dumps when it comes to the deviants i
mean we saw a few tidbits here and there
but nowhere near as much as the eternals
if i'm being honest with you guys i
think the deviants are going to be kind
of a minor part of the film like the
main villain for the first part of the
film and like that's really going to
kind of be it not a whole lot going on
there and then you actually get into the
meat and potatoes of the film which
deals with the celestials coming back to
earth and that kind of makes sense right
the celestials eradicating all life on
earth
is really more important than
the deviants causing problems for
mankind so the real question you have to
ask here is why would the celestials be
showing up on earth to eradicate all
life there honestly not really knowing
anything about the film because you know
it's not out yet we can only really
guess that with half the life being
wiped out in the universe and then in
turn basically being reinstated that
perhaps the plan is just ready for
harvesting now how does this harvesting
process work okay so in marvel comics it
used to be and when i say used to be i
mean like back in the days of stan lee
and jack kirby it used to be that when
the celestials showed up to a world and
judged it it was based explicitly on the
experimentation of the celestials right
so the celestials would show up to a
world they would conduct an experiment
then they would leave right they would
experiment on the on the races of that
world then they would just leave right
and they would just kind of go do their
own thing and then they would eventually
come back to see how their experiment
progressed now fortunately for earth in
the main marvel universe the entirety of
the celestial's experimentation came to
fruition in franklin richards so
basically we were saved right the son of
mr fantastic from the fantastic four who
can alter reality on a universal scale
that dude literally saved everybody on
earth by just existing but the way this
works is that when the celestials come
back to judge their experiments if the
experiment is deemed to be a failure
then the celestials will judge against
the planet specifically irish and the
judge will judge against the planet and
they'll wipe it they would completely
and totally sanitize the water when i
mean sanitized i mean sanitize like
every ounce of life is completely
eradicated then the gardener celestia
will step in and then basically plant
life seeds and regrow the planet and
then the whole process will start all
over again that's the way it used to be
in more recent years all that's changed
instead in eternals vol 4 by charles nof
in 2009 what you end up learning here is
that the celestials are only one part of
the equation the other part of the
equation is a group called the horde
which is literally a space army of bugs
i'm not even lying but the whole idea
behind this is it all all really sources
from a being called the fulcrum who may
or may not be god in all comics it's
pretty ambiguous but in order to balance
out good and evil in the universe the
horde and the celestials exist as
antithesis to each other that the
celestials represent what you could call
good and the horde represent what you
could call evil and so when it's time
for a planet to be harvested to be
reaped then basically what happens is
the planet is completely and totally
sanitized but if the the life signal
basically the morality of the planet
lended itself towards the deviants which
were basically just twisted evil beings
then all the life energy of that world
would go to the horde and that if a
world had a kind of energy signature or
the morality of the eternals which is
basically goodness and all that kind of
stuff that energy would go to the
celestials now a lot of this did seem to
have a major part in the idea of the
celestials modifying the genes of these
people on this world and then basically
you know creating deviants and eternals
and then of course in the case of earth
modifying genes of people to get mutants
later on like a lot of that's still
intact so it's really more of the
celestials initiate the process and then
once the judgment process takes place
the life energy is either given to the
celestials or to the horde themselves
but it's one of those newer concepts
which is not overly important i mean in
all reality it's not super important
here um honestly i don't really know
what the significance of why the
celestial showing up on earth would be
in terms of wiping out all earth because
you would think that if humanity had
elevated itself to a point where it had
the most powerful weapon in the universe
and didn't use it to conquer the
universe that's kind of a good thing
right i mean am i wrong here that's kind
of a good thing right like the avengers
not just becoming these just
dark and sadistic dictators of the
universe that just bend everything to
their whim that's reserved for another
reality where the celestials became the
mad celestials and conquered the
universe that was a really cool story
the important thing here is that there
is a kind of process when it comes to
this how it's going to unfold in the mcu
i'm not entirely sure i mean the mcu is
taking a lot of liberties here which i
don't necessarily have a problem against
right i've been reading comments for 25
years i don't really want to see the
same story that i've read in a comic
book repeated in film form because to me
it would be boring i want to see things
that are different things that are
unique and what they're doing with the
mcu eternals really seems different and
unique i like it having said that i
still stick by the idea this should have
been the first trailer first trailer was
boring as hell first trailer didn't
really tell us anything it just said
like hey like here's here's the eternals
and here's some kind of cool music and
basically we've watched and done nothing
for like the last however many thousands
of years in the face of like humanity
fighting in giant wars and thanos
blinking out half the life in existence
which really begs the question why did
the eternals not do what they were
supposed to like why didn't they step in
even though the celestials told them to
i mean the eternals violate the will of
the celestials all the time in the
comics so i don't know maybe they're
robots and like they're programmed to
just do whatever the celestials tell
them to do so they quite literally could
not bypass their programming i have no
idea i don't know i'm just throwing
throwing stuff out there it's just it's
weird right it's the mcu they can do
whatever they want with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
and i will catch you all later peace